all right hopefully holy crap
although we've been going we were going
for three hours so it's not like yeah
no we went for three hours and uh that
gave people a break go to the restroom
refill drinks whatever do whatever they
were doing saw some meat out like we
were doing today
please uh gonna make it like the video
couldn't like the stream people this
we're waiting for everybody to show up
we only got
we got nine now went from four to nine
hi boogie they're all starting to come
in pookie's been [ __ ]
with me i went in there and i started to
prep patty melts we had patty melts last
night i made my own
damn thousand island dressing everything
was good and then um
i had enough to do it again so we're
gonna have patty melts again she we
should have made two but
two a piece last time we were like oh
man that was good i want another one
[ __ ] all i've eaten today is two little
bitty tacos yeah i haven't eaten much
i've been burning some of this fat off
trying to get literally all i've eaten
today yeah
the uh yeah but i made some
let me tell you guys something before
everybody's starting to come they're
starting to show up
hi deborah just made it in yeah yeah we
went for three hours and then our [ __ ]
crashed so we had to start over
right and everybody took a break
probably the bathroom [ __ ]
get a drink you know but i was just
saying i'm making patty melts again i'm
prepping i'm [ __ ] thawing out
i bought some of those angus beef
patties from sam's big old stack of them
those are actually pretty they're
real good real good better than i
thought the regular beef ones aren't
quite as good but
the angus ones are good and then
made my own thousand island dressing
that way i can make a
patty melt and i found out something
normally you know thousand island is
just nothing more than
ketchup mayonnaise mustard and relish or
chopped pickles
with a little bit of seasoned salt in it
ah i added a little bit of sriracha
into that [ __ ] oh man it [ __ ] set it
off
oh is that what you did yeah a little
bit of sriracha in it do you know why
it's called thousand island
no no why i don't know either i wondered
if you knew
no there's a thousand little
[ __ ] islands
going on down there yeah and they all
make their own
uh salad dressing and something i don't
know
if anybody knows why it's called
thousand island yeah i'd be really
curious
i mean well yeah but i don't know what
that is offhand
yeah and i'm kind of interested in that
kind of [ __ ] another way i cheat when i
make that [ __ ] is i don't like the
[ __ ] i don't like to mince onions or
if i can chop onions all the time
even though i got fresh onions sometimes
i say [ __ ] it
i bought a big old thing of dried diced
onions
from sam's i put them in a dam
two cup or a one cup container
throw some water in there microwave it
yeah
[Laughter]
come back and there's onions already so
i do cheat people
that works too well you know i do cheat
we got other [ __ ] to do got other [ __ ]
to do
and that's what they're doing in a lot
of those fast food restaurants anyway
and the thing about it is like you make
a lot of stuff from scratch
but i mean yeah
if you made everything from scratch that
would be all you did that's all you'd be
doing all day long all day
and i mean you're in there a long time
as it is yeah
but being there all day for one meal or
two i mean we don't really eat
we don't really eat like three minutes i
don't eat breakfast like hardly ever i
have a cup of coffee
sometimes i'll bring you a brunch yeah
sometimes it's a little brunch like
i'm making omelets yeah or something
like that and then
so we'll either have brunch or lunch if
we have brunch it's usually about
yeah and it's an omelette or something
like that and
if we're just having if we're having
lunch lunch it'll be probably like one
or two
yeah and then we'll have dinner maybe
six or seven
maybe that's it dj maniac says that the
diet version of a thousand island is
five hundred hundred
five hundred islands i've heard that one
i've heard that one yeah um
have you seen overlord did you like it
we saw in the theater yeah
it was pretty it was okay
thing with the overlord is this
i was kind of pissed because my my unit
was in
operation overlord the person the 506.
operation overlord was a real mission
it was parachuting and parachuting or
[ __ ] paragliding
over the [ __ ] defenses of d-day while
there was the land invasion
were taken out they were taking france
back from the germans
if you're gonna do set this in
the time frame of operation overlord
it's gotta be historically accurate if
not it's gonna piss a dude like me off
and what pissed me off is that they had
black troops mixed in with the white
troops
now it was a segregated army back then
all right so it shouldn't have been
segregated but it was
that was central you know what i mean
it's kind of like
denying the way it really was i don't
like that although i just kind of
approached it as like an alternate
history
yeah it would only be a alternate
history and then there was a lot of
weird
and here's another thing operation
overlord the first couple days was
nothing but pure chaos
the power had been cut to france so
there wasn't any electricity and they
showed them using electricity
your average [ __ ] sitting in the
audience wouldn't know that
but operation overlord was one of the
largest cluster [ __ ] known to man
the paratroopers and the gliders all
landed in the wrong spots had a lot of
the dudes drowned
they got machine guns on their way down
when they hit the ground a lot of them
didn't have their weapons they had to
find weapons or they had the wrong
weapons
nobody was in charge they ran they ran
around doing
uh field improvised commando raids
is what they did which that was the good
thing about it
the germans the german high command
couldn't figure out what the [ __ ] was
going on
they didn't know how to defend against
thousands of dudes just doing whatever
they wanted to do
real hard to figure out what your
enemy's doing when they just do whatever
the [ __ ] they want to do
there was no plan it was just [ __ ] up
the germans
take over do what you can to survive
yeah yeah and
on the back of that strength
the [ __ ] the street cred of the two
units that i served in the 327th and the
506 was built
on the street cred because both of my
units were involved in that
their street cred is built on basically
that invasion
is that you don't need a commander you
can go out there and take over an entire
country just
by pulling it out of your ass a couple
days later they were all reorganized
though
and it kind of led credence to airborne
warfare that
soldiers can fall from the sky one way
or the other and [ __ ] your ass up
and yeah it works
when that when you need that kind of
stuff nowadays it's kind of
technologically obsolete
you don't really need to do that anymore
because countries don't defend
themselves that way
and it was before missiles you know
and [ __ ] jets and air superiority and
hypersonic [ __ ] missiles and
a lot of what you saw basically
everything you saw in world war ii is
now technologically obsolete
there's a cheaper easier way to do that
the armies of the future will not have
uniforms and they'll be private
companies
it's called low signature you can't see
them they're camouflaged
their true camouflage is not to be in a
uniform at all
but to be dressed like a pizza delivery
man that's true camouflage
somebody the dominoes wars the dominoes
you hear a [ __ ] dominoes versus pizza
hut yeah
papa john's and a fight to the death the
war of the future is you're sitting at
your house
you pass some law that people don't like
or somebody didn't like you [ __ ]
somebody over somewhere else
doorbell rings you go up pizza man's
there you say i didn't order pizza but
aren't you tom's yeah i'm tom and dude
gotcha [ __ ] that's that's the ultimate
guy
and then he disappears and goes back to
a hotel and sleeps
that's that's the war that and that's
what delta force does now
some [ __ ] out of james bond but okay
mike says uh do you like the david
cronenberg film crash from 1996. we were
actually talking about this
uh i actually really liked it i think i
saw in the theater actually
um have you seen it did you see it
what's that crash no
the david cronin we were talking about
it earlier yeah that's what i said i'm
pretty sure you haven't seen it
yeah i really james spader was in it
yeah you know
people that got erotically uh aroused by
car accidents and like being in traction
and whatnot
so you know it's kind of weird but i i
really liked it
dj maniac says so essentially the 80
1980s gi joe cartoon tom which every
member edge had every member of the
village people in their ranks
oh my god the village people yeah
yeah future war will be what's called
low signature war most people won't even
know that it's happening
yeah another sexiest and horror
somebody's nominating
jennifer aniston from the first well one
of the leprechaun movies
yeah one of her first movies was uh
leprechaun was it leprechaun 4
i want to say it was leprechaun or but
maybe not maybe it was an earlier one
because i feel like uh didn't texas
chainsaw the new generation had [ __ ]
renee zellweger and matthew mcconaughey
and that [ __ ]
before they were famous something kind
of strangely compelled about renee
zellweger
she's kind of one of them big bone girls
that i'd like to [ __ ] chase after
every day you know i'm talking about
like them big boys did you ever did you
ever see
uh bridget jones's diary no
kind of a chick flick but actually it
was kind of like fun and actually i
i think i read the book too for whatever
reason i don't know why i ended up
reading the book because it's not the
kind of book i usually read
but because i'm not real into that
chiclet thing even though i don't like
to use that term because that seems like
oh it's for women so it's like crappy
but i don't know it's uh i don't really
like that genre
but for some reason bridget jones's
diary i kind of like thought was really
funny i guess it was kind of like darkly
because it was like kind of sarcastic
and snarky and i liked that
but uh the movie was actually not too
bad it's kind of rom-comey but not
in a really obnoxious way you know what
i mean no
um i didn't see it i have no idea what
you're talking about no i'm just saying
yeah and
what was that motherfucker's name that
uh [ __ ]
hugh grant he was in it dude hugh grant
was in it yeah
yeah yeah that did or wait am i thinking
of some other movie
i'm pretty sure hugh graham was in it
too it's been a long time since i've
seen it
but that's i read the book too i know
there was another one there was another
book
i don't know if they made another movie
there was another book i didn't read
that one
hey tila what was renee zellweger was
that a becky
just checking with you i think that was
a becky go ahead i just love that she
that the first movie she was in as far
as i know let's see texas chainsaw the
first
generation or the next generation which
i don't think she likes she puts that on
her resume or anything yeah because she
won an oscar later
yeah i can't remember what she was there
for
didn't she play judy garland like
recently i thought she got nominated for
an oscar for that
i've been wanting to see that i think
i'm thinking of the same girl
you don't even know what i'm talking
about you're too drunk now
[Laughter]
let me see you pretty sure we're talking
no we're not talking about the same one
okay well never mind the one that i was
thinking about was the dark-haired girl
from um
from um
from chucky pride of checking
that would be jennifer tilly yeah that's
what i was thinking of jennifer tilly
jennifer kelly is hot as [ __ ] yeah thank
you tilly is also hot as she yeah
meg tilly was in psycho too
yeah um jennifer tilly was in well she
was in a bunch of [ __ ] too but she was
probably most famous for being in
yeah i'm looking at it jennifer tilly
that's that's like i always liked her
yeah she's kind of this big boned kind
of
i've always thought she was cute she's
kind of gothy looking yeah
yeah she did have a skinny mode
yeah yeah but i didn't really remember
her that way i remember her more like
that
yeah yeah yeah she was bright at chucky
yeah
the tillies are all hot yeah i agree do
you guys remember what was that [ __ ]
movie that meg tilly was in
uh agnes of god do you guys remember
that
jane fonda was in it too and it was just
kind of about this
meg tilly played a nun and she was
supposedly a virgin but yet she was
pregnant and she
like thought that jesus had impregnated
her
god or god had impregnated her and so
like jane fonda was playing like the
psychologist that was trying to figure
out what the [ __ ] was wrong with this
chick
and i remember that being like really
really good i was that was another one
that was kind of like on cable all the
time like back in the old days and for
some inexplicable reason i just kind of
fixated on it
i don't know why it's not a horror movie
really but it's kind of like a weird
a weird creepy drama
you know what i'm saying i guess owen
bound that was a good movie too you
would love that that's like some lesbian
[ __ ]
t comes in and says see i only know
becky based on the infamous call your
manager so
i'm not sure which one which i thought
that was like a karen thing though
that's more like karen yeah call your
match that's a carrot yeah it's like let
me talk to your manager
it's a specific haircut that they have
yeah specific
and i know and i haven't worked retail
in like decades but i know the exact
type of person yeah
it's always like [ __ ] there's
always this kind of like slightly like
upper middle class
woman and they all have the same kind of
haircut and the same kind of like
clothing doesn't have to be over middle
class well it's kind of that would be
they could be lower middle class well
yeah but it's always kind of like the
same
sort of they they always have this like
entitled attitude
like you guys are all here to serve me
type of [ __ ]
that original uh that original [ __ ]
karen the one that was calling the
police on people barbecuing
that was a lower middle class [ __ ]
that's true
i mean yeah it does that's where it
should start i'm just saying that they
will call and gonna call them call the
police on my neighbors who are the
barbecue
barbecue in their own backyard yeah
whatever
so no it wasn't their own but they were
at a park i think weren't they
well there's been more than one incident
like that yeah
it was just trying to get in people's
[ __ ] where it doesn't really [ __ ]
matter
the cops have other things to [ __ ] do
okay
and they're well they're just causing
trouble yeah
they're you know they're just causing
trouble because they think they're
entitled to cause trouble
i guess i don't really know what the
thought process is
i don't really get that thought process
yeah
like just butt out get out of people's
lives
are they in your yard naked and [ __ ]
and doing shrooms in your [ __ ] yard
no
then [ __ ] off it doesn't have anything
to do with you just like leave everybody
alone
yeah it's i don't know now when i'm
thinking of a becky i'm thinking of
basically sophie d
with the what yeah sophie d uh yeah that
that's a bet
tila says tom look look uh look up at
wiga fennec oh
yeah i know who you're talking about she
was in like a bunch of uh jello movies
how do you feel um she has it spelled
correctly there
e-d-w-i-g and vega phenomena yeah she
was uh
not italian but she was in a lot of glo
movies
she was in oh [ __ ] man was that one that
i watched the other day
god damn it she was in more than one but
i remember like she yeah she's like
creed or naturally like beautiful but
yeah she was in a bunch of those
she was not one kind of like
psychedelic-y one
[ __ ] i just watched it like the other
day
it wasn't bloodstained butter but it
wasn't bloodstained buttercream
right yeah it's not going for some
reason well your shit's [ __ ] up
obviously she's saying my [ __ ] is [ __ ]
up
your shit's [ __ ] up uh
danny rolling ghostface says oh scott
says you can do shrooms in my yard i
don't care
okay you know what's funny is that i was
watching
the time sucks oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah she was in like i said she was in a
ton of uh jell-o movies yeah
she's italian no german she's german
you guys might recognize her yeah she's
a hottie yeah yeah
i was gonna say too as far as horror
hotties go uh what about barbara steele
you guys barbra steele
she's a bread and she was in a lot of
she was an italian move she was in mario
baba movie she's in black sunday
and also she was in some david
cronenberg movies
so you know and she was in horror movies
later on too
she was in one i saw a couple years ago
called the butterfly room
which was a total uh she played the
murderer in that
um spoiler alert but it was totally like
over the top and dramatic but i still
loved it
she looks italian but german
[Laughter]
yeah yeah for male horror hottie the guy
that played dwayne
the brunette vampire in lost boys okay
yeah
he played uh and he played in the remake
of invasion of the bonnie snatchers okay
i know you're talking about
i know you're talking about i thought
keith for sutherland was pretty foxy in
that
and he was pretty foxy in flatliners too
then he was like he's on 24. he got he
was on 24 like later on
i don't know they were pretty they're
pretty good looking those other ones
she was in the pit in the pendulum yeah
that's right
i remember her from god damn it
the blood-stained orchid i think was the
name of the one that she was in
i think that's what i remember her bro
but she was in like she was in a bunch
of giallo movies
um vanetta mcgee who played luva or tina
and blacula
also another beauty yeah that's a good
one um
maybe she did a cameo in hostel too did
i even see hostile 2
i saw the first hostel in theaters and i
liked it but i don't really remember
if i bothered seeing the other ones it
was kind of like the saw franchise
i saw the first saw movie in the theater
and i dug it but then like when sequels
started coming out i was like meh
i don't know i was like yeah i saw
enough of that i'm not one of those
people to say who is torture poor and
blah blah but it's just kind of like
i don't know it's not my favorite genre
but i'll watch it
some of them were good seven
bloodstained orchids thank you
that's what it was called and it was
something with blood and organs in it
ingrid pitt another good uh pick she was
in a lot of uh
hammer movies as well they made a lot of
really good [ __ ]
erotic horror movies back in the day
i was thinking about doing one of the
ones i put in the poll i'm not sure what
the
polls are this week but fearless vampire
killers
there was all this kind of like lesbian
ones like about uh
[ __ ] what's her face uh
[ __ ] what's her name that woman that's
supposedly like
candace bathory there you go it's
bathroom yeah yeah there were there were
a bunch to like about that like countess
dracula and
all that because you know there's so
much um
potential there for showing boobies it
was a good movie though
it was the hammer version it was good
yeah olivia hussey that's another good
that's another good uh pick she was in
black christmas and
psycho four she played norman bates's
mom
um let's see what else
what are you nothing don't worry about
it i can see what the hell's going on as
good as [ __ ]
show okay all right hold on
what'd you find this all right what did
you find
that's a backy
there you go t that's a backyard wait
who is that though it's just a random
i thought that becky
was just not like that i thought that
becky was just like a thick
girl well that's what that was right but
with just like a big
huge butt yeah i showed it
okay that's not exactly that's bad
well it was an actual becky not a
simulated glamorized becky it was the
actual becca that was the real thing
an actual bathroom that was an actual
bed not a simulation no
not a drill no you know outside okay
she's asked me to go outside just pepper
says
what does a becky do
they eat pickle pig's feet they eat
grits
they uh ride around the back of a truck
so did
so did the becky nomenclature hold on
one sec
did the becky nomenclature come from the
uh the song you know what i mean
where did he go did that come from
babies got back
to go he's checking on the meat probably
i kind of feel like that came from the
sir mix-a-lot song
baby's got back because remember at the
beginning it had that oh my god becky
look at her butt it was that i thought
that was where the nomenclature
came from but i could be totally totally
wrong about that i'm not entirely sure
where the karen nomenclature came from
i just remember being aware of that well
like i said
i was asking them i was at them and you
but you were here um
did the becky nomenclature come from the
sir mix-a-lot song
yeah that's what i found yeah yeah oh my
god
yeah yeah yeah look at her butt even
though
the person that they were talking about
wasn't named becky she was talking to
her jackie was saying
she was talking to her friend becky oh
my god becky look at her
yeah yeah she wasn't talking about a
girl well no that girl might have been
named becky too we don't know
in the 90s in the 90s
in the 90s when i was in the army
up in the infantry black guys just in
general
called white girls that looked like that
around the base
are around your fort this is down and
[ __ ] four cannibals
they're just the becky yeah they were
all just kind of generic becky
yeah well that's what they were talking
about
all right yeah yeah yeah yeah well i
kind of feel like
you know somewhere where i used to work
um we used to do uh graphic design
for a couple of like junior league type
so sort of middle up like upper middle
class women and they were all kind of
like karen's actually
yeah but um they were real
obnoxious but we called them muffies
or actually my my manager used to call
them uh
muffy buffy stuffy that's what she used
to call him but she we just called them
muffies for short yeah
because they were you know upper class
like muffy
like april fool's day if you guys saw
that movie that girl's name was muffy
just happened just paper says what does
it becky do and you love
yeah tom we got a lot of those in cali
yeah and then [ __ ] rick says a big
butt becky
yeah straw dog says a lot of becky's in
my neck of the woods
you see i say this crazy [ __ ] jenny
thinks that people won't know what the
[ __ ] i'm talking about
everybody's that sort of back you know
exactly what i'm [ __ ] talking i don't
think it says
i don't think it's as common nowadays as
karen if you say yeah
karen everybody knows what that is yeah
but karen is very different from about
yeah karen and becky are two different
things yeah that's two different things
and like i said back in the old days i
kind of feel like
when we talked about muffies we were
talking about it was kind of like a
quasi-karen
it wasn't exactly the same just pepper
googled it she said
she said becky's are basically i think
white girl yes very basic
[Laughter]
it's not she's not ugly she's not hot
she's thick she's drinking some pumpkin
spice yeah
he might be fun to hang out with she
might be fun to hang out with i'm not
judging i love [ __ ] space
yes they do vary
they have some becky's are hotter than
other becky's
they do all kind of have that same
general [ __ ] build they're all kind
of thick
some of it's pleasant some of it isn't
it depends on
genetics i guess you know
but that was a becky and we called him
becky's too
yeah that was kentucky you know yeah
yeah we called them too but it meant
basic
you know what i mean you call them back
into their face
yeah yeah i mean but yeah you go out
there and [ __ ] becky you know it's it
just depends it depends on what the
situation was it's just a becky
tila said first time i heard becky was
barbecue becky the one who called the
cops on the blackberry bar no
like meredith pre-dates that [ __ ] yeah i
had heard that like before
i'd heard that before and i think it
goes back to that sir mix-a-lot song
well i think he's referring to becky i
think i think actually it was around
before that probably around the same
time
maybe contemporary justification just
meant basic white girl
yeah probably southern
you know and uh but not necessarily
not necessarily but that's not who most
guys that i knew were referring to
they're referring to tennessee kentucky
you know or outside the military bases
and they looked just like the girl that
i showed there that was just a very
basic
most of them were about like that and it
wasn't necessarily a bad thing
some of them were better looking than
others you know
some becky's are bigger than yeah
becky could be [ __ ] obese all right
um becky's were never really skinny
though you know
becky was at least medium build
but like i said some women can really
hold
medium weight so even heavy weights
sometimes they're gonna look pretty good
you know especially when you're [ __ ]
in your 20s and you haven't had any in a
while but no they still
and it was a uh kind of easygoing
personality but there really wasn't much
magic there you know what i mean [ __ ]
you know they're not
real educated or they're not real
talented if they if they were they
wouldn't be there
you know what i mean they're left
already well like you said they're kind
of basic
they're really bad they don't have
anything like superheroes nothing about
them not really
kind of you know they have them here in
florida when we went to the club last
time you know all those people were
dancing
they're like they're there yeah yeah
same thing yeah it's just they're not
quite the
the other ones that we were so they were
pretty ones most of them yeah
there was okay there was one becky
remember the big girl that had the
[ __ ] stripper shoes on
little [ __ ] cutoffs in the yeah that
was a [ __ ] mega bat
that was a super becky it was an uber
becky yeah
yeah back outside of middletown
back outside an infantry [ __ ] four
they had been fighting over that becky
yeah he actually looked pretty good for
a big girl you know man both [ __ ]
yeah
yeah yeah that's what we came in those
damn stripper shoes with the [ __ ]
cutoffs
yeah i was just like yeah she becky's
looking for trouble
[Laughter]
she came here to get laid yeah there
there were some uh
some pretty like prime examples of it
right exactly that's how we went out
yeah you could show
the mega bag you could tell this by
women's shoes if she's there to get laid
or not and she was trying to well they
don't call them [ __ ] me pumps for
anything
although those were not [ __ ] bombs
those are straight up strippers
straight up porn [ __ ] me pumps is a
different category no there's a straight
up [ __ ] porn platforms
tila says i'd rather be a heather
heathers are [ __ ] with your damn
heather down in the valley little valley
girls
don't blame me yeah
oh my god yeah scott says mega becky
ripping up waffle houses gojira stuff
yeah that's exactly what we're talking
about should have a [ __ ] sausage in
each hand
big thing of [ __ ] flapjacks
[ __ ] all kinds of damn [ __ ] maple
syrup dripping off the edges
like god eating like it's a sexual like
like eating like it's a sexual event
yeah it's all like erratic and [ __ ] well
it's
okay mega becky looks good
i love this discussion that quebec he
looked until you knock it up
she gets pregnant and all of a sudden
all everything you saw in her goes away
they get big
[Laughter]
they get big they're okay job done it's
all this soft job done i'm just gonna go
ahead and [ __ ] just gain some weight
sit here and
have these children yep that's push them
out that's what they do
that's what they do got those heathers
have a short lifespan
you know what's really funny is that
because i feel like the year that i was
born which was 1972.
uh jennifer was the most popular name
that's one i got salad with
and i think i'm not sure about
statistics but i think the second most
popular name is heather
because when i got to high school one of
my classes which didn't have that many
people in it
there were five jennifers and like three
or four heathers
okay so there was like a lot of that
[ __ ] going on that's why we thought it
was so funny when that movie heathers
came out in 89 or 1990 which was like
you know when i was my senior year
senior year of high school
because we knew so many people named
heather even though jennifer was a more
common name
but jennifer didn't have the same
stigma to it i guess as heather had yeah
which is really funny because nobody
thinks about that when you're naming
your baby
like you don't think about but but
actually like what you name your baby
does like have a lot of uh
impact about it he asks who frequents
cracker barrel more
becky karen or heather and i'm gonna say
becky yeah
yeah definitely i don't know especially
becky's mom and becky's
karen would not be caught dead in a
cracker barrel yeah
[ __ ] this yeah it's really me you i mean
karen would be in the starbucks for sure
yeah i'm going to boston market yeah
does anybody get a boston market anymore
i'm not sitting on boston market
i like boston market [ __ ] this i'm going
to boston market
i kind of feel like they're like karen's
are more like a starbucks
or um you know like uh
like a salad kind of place like yeah
whispers or something
or like a yo or like a yogurt place you
know what i'm saying
yeah that's more like a karen kind of
environment it's an uptight type [ __ ]
cracker barrel is much and i'm not
[ __ ] on starbucks either because i
love that i love [ __ ] starbucks but
i kind of feel like becky that's a
that's a cracker barrel environment
becky's mom goes becky goes with her
whole family
yeah and i got to say something though
man
cracker barrel it's got great breakfast
if you want a good breakfast you got a
[ __ ] bread cracker bro
got good almonds got good [ __ ]
breakfast i give you toast
and all kinds of [ __ ] pancakes back
in the day before we had a cracker
barrel in daytona
uh we had we used to go to the bob evans
yeah
to get biscuits and gravy yeah like if
we had like grandma with us and stuff
like that bob evans is a very
old clientele yeah very cool clientele
when you go there make sure you're going
to see some dentures you're going to see
walkers you're going to see lots of
[ __ ] gray white hair and coupons
you see coupons
some support hose yeah all you can drink
coffee you just keep pouring it around
oh hey i like that
yeah you know i was gonna sit there
forever and talk to the waitress
yeah pinch their cheeks yeah
yeah cause you remind me we got one
[ __ ] what about six miles up here
what a cracker barrel it's cross dog
barking holy [ __ ] across the street from
[ __ ]
memories of india that's right there is
a crack i've never been in it no never
mind
bob evans oh okay i didn't i didn't even
think they were still around
yeah yes bob evans i remember going to
the one that's the red white one right
yeah yeah yeah it's bob evans over there
i don't even know what else they serve
other than biscuits and gravy because
that's literally all i've ever eaten
there
fake country food scott says becky would
definitely go to the golden corral oh
yeah
yeah duffs or any buffet restaurant yep
that's exactly right they go to the
chinese buffet too
tear it up although so do we yeah we
gotta say we can't judge yeah
i don't know i don't know man like
chinese buffet that might be a little
too exotic for becky no no no no they
went to that
yeah we haven't lived around we have
well because the thing about it is a lot
of chinese buffets and the one that we
go to
koi wan is no exception they also yeah
they have all the chinese food and
you know japanese food they have sushi
and stuff but also they have chicken
nuggets french fries
and like a quote-unquote american food
for kids you know
becky goes to cece's pizza yeah that's
it
that's definitely a becky man yeah becca
go to species and eat
all you she can eat pizza and then
they'll eat
the pasta too because they have that
[ __ ]
and then she'll have the dessert pizza
yeah [ __ ] becky
i went in there quick and went in to see
every time i go into cece's there's
becky's in it
[Laughter]
yeah most of them white there's a couple
of black becky's in there too because
becky's not necessarily
they're not all just white they got
black ones too and hispanic becky's
they're mostly white though yeah i'm
pretty nervous that's like a majority
yeah the becky phenomenon it kind of
mutates into something else when they're
non-whites
it's the same person they're just you
just have to come up with another
definition for it
it's just it's a different it's
different culture but it it's the same
it's
different expressions of the same person
this is like this is a funny this is a
funny discussion
because everybody knows exactly what
type of person everybody knows exactly
what we're talking about scott says
please make mega becky t-shirts
[Laughter]
i would really i would like to see a
shirt with a becky
just like crushing ooh wouldn't it be
funny if she was crushing
a cracker barrel yeah although you'd
have to call it something else like
smacker
narrower what's funny is that dude
what's funny is that when i was talking
about
the mega becky from from from madigan
jenny knew exactly what i was talking
about i knew who you were talking about
exactly well there were a lot of becky's
there though that one stood out though
but [ __ ] yeah and that one stood out as
a mecca
if you got if i got if i had pictures of
it you guys didn't know exactly what i
was talking about
and [ __ ] almost all you dudes that we're
hearing what i'm talking about you go
yeah i'd hit that
because she was like the queen of the
becky's you know what that is
you know exactly what that is queen
becky it's like one of the queen of the
bag
she would eat the cracker barrel yeah
well you know it was funny like okay so
we went to mannequins on saturday
and um so paul and tina were there
uh you know that paul vane used to dj
way back in the day like it [ __ ] uh
you know he did venue 13 he did like
massage he did like all the good [ __ ]
like back in orlando
and so they were there doing uh
flashback saturdays that's like their
new thing
so downtown sanford is not quite as hip
and cool
as downtown orlando and i'm not saying
that downtown orlando is super hypno but
downtown stanford is significantly less
hypno um just in the sense of the people
that hang out
there's a lot of cool people that hang
out down there but there's a lot of kind
of like becky ass like and becky
adjacent people that hang out down there
too
and uh it gets a little obnoxious so we
were there we're hanging out with the
bar
he was like he was playing some [ __ ]
awesome music man like he even played
like the fall and [ __ ] and i was like
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
killing joke but
you couldn't really dance because there
were so many like drunk ass becky and
becky adjacent people like kind of
dancing and like stinking up the joint
or whatever
so i was just kind of like okay well i'm
just gonna stay over here and drink
until they
[ __ ] off and leave so they did that and
then so
finally most of them left so and then he
was playing some gothy [ __ ] like he
played like [ __ ] old scissors of
mercy he played like some
like cool [ __ ] so you know me and a
couple of other kind of old-school like
goth chicks out there dancing you were
kind of dancing
yeah and there was still like a little
group of becky sort of
yeah people like out there dancing and
they would ever requested something i'm
like oh this should be good
yeah it's [ __ ] healing he laughed
like well like
well because we've we've known like paul
forever
yeah we saw that she went up there and
i'm like oh this should be good let's
see what she requested she requested
oh you saw it yeah you saw i didn't see
it what's your request
she requested that beechy's song abhija
song the bee gees oh okay
remember more than a woman yeah yeah
people dance to it though well well see
that's the thing
i think she thought that we would le
that all the gods would leave
so i have no we all danced no we were
all like all right bgs we're doing that
yeah yeah we i knew the word
he didn't understand what she was doing
i'm like [ __ ] we know the bee gees too
yeah that's a good song yeah and it
actually blended right into whatever it
was he was playing at the time
yeah yeah no
based on the comments no becky's are not
fat
not necessarily they're just kind of
they're kind of
regular anglo american
or celtic american kind of irish
american
mostly southern
kind of country breeding stock that's a
good way to put it that's kind of what
it is
they're kind of like just breeding stock
women they're just the normal very basic
white girls that you'd see
and they do range in in in in weight
from obese to very skinny
but most becky's are kind of just big
bone they're just like a big bum farm
girl
sure most of that's what i would say
yeah it's becky dj maniac says we used
to clear the club out at 4am with
abbott's dancing queen and
all the goths would dance and sing along
to it yeah i'm not surprised i love it
that's what i mean i think people have
this misperception of dots as like these
kind of dour [ __ ] [ __ ] and
we don't know any of that music
[ __ ] we know all that [ __ ] i love that
[ __ ] and the thing about it too is that
if the shit's fabulous then we'll like
yeah it's gonna be just [ __ ] fabulous
and we have a sense of humor
yeah you know what i mean i'm like bg's
all right i'm i'm here for it
and there so they're playing that and
ironically that song has been stuck in
my head since this weekend
i even like even when we got home i
started singing it to pookie i was like
more than a pookie yeah yeah yeah and
she was just kind of like what are you
even talking about mama
yeah and then i was saying it and then i
was singing to my mock man like more
than a moth man to me
yeah i mean there's some olivier new
john songs that would [ __ ] work
really good
[ __ ] yeah a lot of them say yeah magic
oh see that would be so happy
[Music]
i love that though yeah yeah we've
guessed that
yeah i would totally dance to that well
honestly i think you're [ __ ] up
yeah yeah what you know what i don't
even remember
what a company this was that did this
commercial
but this commercial was obviously made
by somebody that knew what they were
talking about
there was a commercial a while back like
i said i can't from what it's for
but there was a bunch of people standing
out
like there was all these goths waiting
to go in a goth club right and they all
looked very dour and they were like
smoking and they're just like
hook up whatever and these two kind of
like normal like
kind of jock looking dudes like came up
in line they're like oh [ __ ] look at
this but we're still going to go in here
so they're waiting in line
and so and they're looking at all these
people waiting in line they all look
like really [ __ ]
yeah they all look pissy and everything
and then they get in the club
and then whams wake me up before you go
go is playing and all the ghats are like
smile and go woo
they're all like dancing and stuff and
i'm like accurate i don't know who i
don't know who made that commercial but
i was like yeah accurate
um if you it's just funny because i just
feel like people think that we're like
[ __ ]
all [ __ ] dour and [ __ ] like that all
the time and it's totally not like that
like i said you play some cheesy [ __ ] i
bar used to don't know if they do
anymore
but they used to do something called
grits and gravy
used to be on tuesday nights and then
they moved it to thursday because me and
you used to go sometimes
and grits and gravy was pretty much they
would play anything
from the 50s to the 70s would be
anything from like rockabilly to disco
um they would play [ __ ] from musicals
and yeah well i mean they could play
they would play like elvis or jerry lee
lewis and they'd play like some abber
they play something from greece or
something like that
and it was super fun it was so fun
and they kind of had their own vibe like
they had their own people that showed up
it was a lot of like hipsters and stuff
like that too
but i think people were surprised to see
that like some gots would show up and be
like and they knew all the [ __ ] songs
you know esther says tom sings the
greatest hits you guys don't even know
half the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
there's been conversations happened
outside the show between me and jenny
where i was gonna do cover songs
because i we have the ability to record
here i just have to
get a good karaoke program that has
good enough background music to do it
there's all kinds of songs i wanted to
sing
and do a professional production on them
and just drop them in the [ __ ] stream
can you remember some of the songs i
wanted to sing i wanted to sing a bunch
of [ __ ]
uh there's a bunch of judas priest i
wanted to say
yeah you had some bo you wanted to say
you wanted some bowie so maybe
a sister of mercy roy orbison yeah like
that
yeah right danzig yeah you
wanted to sing some dancing i wanted to
do
um what was the first one that you
mentioned
oh [ __ ] well now i don't even remember
oh yes oh sisters of mercy yeah i wanted
to do
the judas priest song i wanted to do was
[ __ ] dissident aggressor
and i wanted to do sinner all right back
in the 70s
the bowie songs that i wanted to do was
just
ones you may not know like [ __ ] um
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] stationed the station
that was a good [ __ ] song god says
dude breaking the law
nah two mainstream
dancing songs i wanted to do like
sistina's or
[ __ ] um how the gods kill
i like a lot of like b side [ __ ] slower
type stuff you know or maybe like i'm
going down to die
by danzig that's a good one and
you guys would have liked it i mean [ __ ]
i might still do it we might i mean
we've got like
a little room in there because i do my
audiobooks in there so you just like you
can say you have to um
buy a good service that has the
background music so that's the thing
well you can go to like [ __ ] itunes
and buy
karaoke versions of those songs sure
is it the real song in the background is
that studio musicians recreating it it
depends it depends
um you can i think for copyright reasons
they usually just have somebody
recreating okay um
because a lot of the [ __ ] that's just
like on youtube that you can see the
[ __ ] recordings are terrible
and they're not they're not you'd have i
would pay i mean itunes
i'm not sure how much the karaoke [ __ ]
is but usually they will sell like
like one song for 99 cents okay so it's
not really like that big a deal i
haven't really looked at their catalog
like what kind of karaoke like [ __ ] they
have
uh scott says you should do ribbons
which is actually probably one of my
favorites which one's ribbons sisters
and mercy
oh yeah yeah ribbons yeah i forgot about
that one uh now i was good i was going
to do something off first and last i was
going to do some stuff off first and
last and always
probably better like you should know
nine or amphetamine logic i mean nine
wild nine is probably about yeah
i got that album yeah maybe marianne
yeah that was the one maybe emma real
old stuff like emma
although that's a cover yeah but i want
to do like a version i love it
i want to do i want the sisters of mercy
kind of do in the background
yeah for emma or maybe alice
see alice would be good although a lot
of bands have covered that but
yeah scott says do the whole album i
could do that
i would love to do that whole album yeah
why not
it wouldn't sound just like that for
whatever reason um
i've always wanted to do a version of i
don't know how many of you know the song
but i've always wanted to do a version
of the birthday party song
say a spell i love that [ __ ] song
yeah if you guys don't know what we're
talking about
um there's a band called sisters of
mercy
and they have an album called first and
last and always let's go to ut
that album first and last and always is
the best album ever made
if you ask me and i've said that and
we've had friends and other podcasters
[ __ ] heard me say this and they go
out and listen at me and they come
listen to that album they come back go
yeah that is probably the best album
ever
ever of all times and it's a weird
album it's very weird it's very
melancholy
and it's just very driving and it was a
british band and it's just
they weren't famous too much and they
weren't famous in the day
um the only gods knew about them sisters
of mercy first and last and always i
kind of feel like they got famous a
little bit later it was later
like after they got after the band broke
up they got famous because i kind of
feel like [ __ ] off floodline division
thing got played a lot in clubs
yeah and even in mainstream clubs i kind
of feel like it was yeah later on it
became more club music and more like
even metal it kind of started to go like
la versions of metal
that is not the systems of mercy that
i'm talking about talking about
the first singles the eps that they came
out like with reptile house and stuff
and the uh and the singles like alice
and then
the first and last and always that first
album right there and the covers they
did like i said like emma and
delter and stuff were really good didn't
they they covered a stooges song did
they not
uh yeah i kind of feel like they covered
history and then like after
that album the band broke up it's split
into two
split into mission uk and then the
singer took the name
sisters of mercy with him and turned
that band into basically a metal band
kinda well flood land wasn't metal but
vision thing was
they were it was good but it was a
different band
yeah yeah 1969 yeah thank you i knew
they had done up on you
i knew they'd done a stupid song dj
maniac says i do two sister songs when
you don't see me and i was wrong which
are both fantastic songs yeah
those are both on uh vision vision thing
um
yeah that was a german band doing backup
that was his la
medal yeah uh verse i liked vision thing
but
i at that point i was kind of trying i
was going more toward when i was like
all right i see where this is going go
check out first and last and always
check out that whole album
and then emma which is a single and
alice
and um there was a
gimme shelter which is a [ __ ] stone's
cover they had a lot of good [ __ ] i'll
show you man i'll send you links to it
dj
dj maniac says they toured with public
enemy in 1990 yeah yeah i didn't
remember that happening he said it was
this much of a disaster you can imagine
i remember that because i remember like
hearing about it like who the [ __ ]
that was a good idea terrible yeah it
didn't work out so good
um i remember they didn't play on any
i've seen
sister to mercy live many many many
times but
normally it was just them and an opening
band like it or sometimes not even an
opening band like in a smaller club
they didn't play any of the big tours
like lollapalooza or anything susie and
the banshees did because i saw susie and
the banshees at a lollapalooza
and nine inch nails but i saw ninety
nails like a zillion times and i never
even really meant to
dj medics has been pulling some stuff on
youtube for karaoke today some of it's
got awful either no lyrics no tracer or
poorly rookie yeah
you can't trust what's coming off of
youtube i feel like maybe you should
like buy it pay for it and you'll
probably get better
because i mean if you made a list of
like [ __ ] that you wanted to do right
and then you could like see if it was
available gadgets3 says tom's not gonna
make it no i'm gonna make it dude don't
worry i'm gonna make it i gotta cook
after this
oh [ __ ] i think we lost our stream did
we i think so don't tell me that
well no it's dj maniac says mission uk
is a bit too dreary even for me
yeah same i kind of feel like they're
like a slightly gothier
you too which i liked their very first
album
some of their shit's good i like some of
their songs i like wasteland i like
you know i like some of the [ __ ] mission
uk's very first album is a white album
with a black claw cross on it i forgot
what it's called
but that one is a lot like a sisters of
mercy album it's a lot like first and
last and always
it's it's really good but then like i
said they went in the morning yeah and
then it started
more like youtube kind of like a goth
version of youtube
which kind of made sense because um
you too also um
were cousins with some guys from a goth
bed called virgin prunes
yeah and the virgin prunes i think and
mission uk were friends so they started
to come
become kind of you two-ish i think man i
love them the virgin prunes are really
good
i like them all yeah and um then all
that [ __ ]
yeah severina that's a good song okay
yeah
like i said well i mean wasteland is
probably my favorite song up there what
was the very first uh
i'm gonna check people what was that
first [ __ ] um
mission uk album it might have just been
called the mission
at that time yeah they only called them
the mission uk over here
yeah we already had a band called that i
think we talked about that before
i said like i said i think the week that
i'm
gonna be on vacation which is june 6th
to 11th
like i'll be back on the 11th before we
do the live stream i think
that night we're gonna do like a whole
dedicated
goth music and culture history show
because like i said that's something i
don't have to research all that much
although i still will but i'm just
saying
look at that it doesn't have it it
doesn't have it
it shows 86 being the first one and
that's not right
it's this one we'll see there you go the
first chapter or something first chapter
somebody said that actually oh okay yeah
yeah the first chapter 1987.
yeah there you go scott said that okay
he did he got it i didn't see it
that that album has a [ __ ] a lot of
good songs on it
what songs are on that one
i can't even i didn't have that one i
have i had a couple other ones but
it has one's called dancing barefoot it
has uh oh yeah yeah yeah i remember that
yeah i remember that yeah yeah yeah
it's got tomorrow never knows okay wait
over the hills and far away oh okay
there we go naked and savage
like a hurricane yeah a garden of
delight another good one wishing well
dancing barefoot crystal oats all right
maybe i did have that
that's a good album i had so many i
can't remember yeah
yeah dancing barefoot has got a lot of
this uh i'm dancing
barefoot they headed for a spin
right some strange music takes me in
do you remember that buddy yeah yeah
makes me feel
like i'm on heroin and
i think that's what it is isn't that the
lyrics
yeah i can't remember like i said you'd
remember it better than i do yeah i
wasn't like a massive fan of the
mission i like to dislike some of their
songs and i had
like one one or two of their albums but
i didn't listen to them all that much so
you know
yeah scott said that's it yeah yeah
yeah it makes you feel like i'm on some
kind of heroin or i'm on some heroin
yeah you got it they had a [ __ ]
heavy uh mission had a lot of [ __ ]
references to [ __ ] heroin and
morphine you know
god's own medicine wasn't even one of
the air yeah of course
i kind of feel like everybody was sort
of on heroin back then yeah well it's a
heroin
chic of the [ __ ] elite i mean a lot
of the people like
some people like very famously like i
said nick cape was all actually a victim
and uh although gotta say i kind of
liked this [ __ ] when he was on heroin
yeah
and if you've any if any of you have
ever read
his novel and the ass saw the angel
um clearly written by somebody on drugs
and yet
still quite awesome i kind of wish they
would make a movie out of it although it
would be batshit insane
scott said on some kind of heroin yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i gotta hear that album again it's been
a while
youtube exists yeah it is it and i'm
sure someone has uploaded it
yeah no it's there it's there i know
it's there scott says nick cave in the
bad seats the song from wings of desire
they did a couple they did um a new
version of from her to eternity
uh because that movie came out in 87
yeah so
the original version of from her to
eternity was on his first
album which was called from her to
eternity which came out in the early
thank you david june
super chat five dollars tila find me
five dollars here's my pen
thank you very much for being late
because he didn't get an uh notification
for the second one yeah we lost the
stream
you're going to get spanked by tila oh
dear yeah although you have to pay me
for that
[Laughter]
how's that going to work out very
confident
i got these beautiful ebony supermodels
coming spanking these
[ __ ] white boys i'm gonna get paid
somehow i'm gonna work it out with her
that was he was like even though i have
nothing to do with it
i'm gonna work that [ __ ] out i'm gonna
work that out with t's husband somehow
yeah yeah no what i was gonna say was
that from her to eternity was the first
nick cave solo album after he left the
birthday party and when it came out in
like 84.
um and which some days is actually my
favorite one it's very rudimentary but
i'm kind of into it
uh it has [ __ ] from her to a charity
it's a [ __ ] great song
saint huck which i love you know all
that kind of [ __ ]
i thought they did another song for
wings of desire too i think the carny
was maybe in there too
we were just saying well wait a minute
i'm talking okay okay this is funny with
this yeah
bend over dave hahaha yeah they get yeah
they take my money yeah
the money's changing hands in their
spanking okay
okay so we're pretending that he's back
yeah we're spending on that
all right yeah no but i'm saying i think
if i remember i haven't seen wings of
desire in a long time
but um i think the carny was in there
too
which was actually on his
86 album which was called your funeral
my trial
honestly i'm still waiting somebody out
there that knows how to do animation
somebody do an animated ver it could be
stop motion animation or it could just
be like some kind of rough ass looking
animation
somebody do an animated version of his
song the carny i can see
every time i hear that song i can hear
it i can see it like in my mind's eye
and i don't know how to do animation
like i know how to do it but i don't
have the patience
and somebody needs to animate the story
of that song that would be so [ __ ]
great
you know what i mean because that song's
super long it's like [ __ ] eight
minutes nine minutes something like that
but it's like a whole story and i i
think that would be really cool if
somebody animated it but nobody's done
it do you want another dream
uh sure why not how much time would has
this stream been going
an hour in an hour okay so we've been on
for about four hours
yeah it's longer well i know
i'm in we talking ball gags or
but yeah man that reminds me i need to
didn't they
okay did not they remake
wings of desire as
didn't they do like an american version
i kind of feel like meg ryan was in it
yeah
was nicholas cage in it or am i totally
crazy it wasn't called wings of desire
it was called something else
does anybody remember what it was
because i remember it not being very
good
the only scene i remember from it is meg
ryan
on a bicycle and she was just kind of
like riding down the road like woo
life's wonderful and then she got hit by
a truck right
am i remembering that wrong city of
angels thank you that's what it was
that's right i remember like laughing my
ass off at that [ __ ] scene
because i knew i knew it was coming she
was going down the street was like
oh my god life is awesome i'm on a
bicycle i'm in the middle of the [ __ ]
highway and then bam the [ __ ] semi
hits her and i was just kind of like oh
my god
you did not just to [ __ ] do that oh
my god so funny
what are they yes city of angels that
was it
it was but it was like so
[ __ ] funny though wings of desire was
[ __ ] great
but the remake what like i don't even
know what the [ __ ] they were even doing
with that i don't remember
it was worse than until the end of the
world now until the end of the world
i remember watching that with my friend
jen over at her house because we i'd
always go over to her house like every
weekend and we would like just watch all
this [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ] this is
mostly where i saw all this [ __ ] because
we didn't have anything we grew up in
daytona where there was nothing to do
so we would just like order a pizza and
go to the [ __ ] video store and like
rent
weird movies so we watched that
and i wanted to see it because of the
soundtrack because the soundtrack is
[ __ ] awesome
and i still love that nick cave song you
know that was in it
and i love a lot of the other songs that
were in it too but i all i remember i
just remember like
watching the movie and then mostly just
like falling asleep halfway which i just
remember being like
really really tedious but it had a great
[ __ ] soundtrack
we'll say um amanda marie says jenny
some
serial killer news there will be another
film about ted bundy
and chad michael murray will star sm all
right
i'm gonna have to check that [ __ ] out
i'm gonna have to check that [ __ ] out
scott says i saw that in the theater oh
my god poor you
when the character said but that was
just the beginning of the two hour mark
the entire audience groaned
i think i had fallen asleep by that
point i mean my friend jen she had this
really really comfortable
couch you know that when all it was like
one of those big l-shaped couches
so that's what we would sit on like
eating the pizza and watching the movies
and i'm pretty sure
that about an hour hour and a half into
that movie i think i had just like
[ __ ] fallen asleep
probably with a piece of pizza like
halfway out of my mouth
you know what i'm saying yeah soundtrack
is great movie was applauding this yeah
so just until the end of the world
skipped the movie but
by the soundtrack the soundtrack's great
but yeah the movie was super boring
[Laughter]
that's just really funny um i was trying
to think of like
what the [ __ ]
i was thinking of some other [ __ ] the
other day about
because nick cave actually went on to
score a bunch of uh western type movies
lately and he also wrote the screenplay
for that movie the proposition
which is fantastic by the way if you
like westerns
did my [ __ ] crash no no my [ __ ] crashed
your [ __ ] yeah
no it's still going we were talking
about the movie until the end of the
world
uh you're not missing anything the
soundtrack's great but the movie was
really really boring and that's cut
that's something coming for me because
you know how much i loved
like my art films but that one i just
couldn't hang with it
couldn't hang with it i fell asleep in
the middle
honestly i have to say the same thing
i'd have to rewatch it but i
i have the same reaction to uh
my own private idaho and i hate to say
that because i know a lot of people love
that movie
pretty sure i fell asleep in the middle
of that movie although i'm willing to
rewatch that one because i know a lot of
people like it
but i remember falling asleep in the
middle of that movie too and like i said
i'm pretty patient i'll watch all kind
of boring [ __ ]
but i think that one maybe i don't know
maybe i was just real sleepy that night
pat says i guess we're done are we done
we're not done are we i don't know are
we it's up to you
i got to get in there and cook how's
how's that meat how's that meat
no that means hanging good
[Laughter]
it should be you know it's thought out
it's all right yeah yeah i can cook it
i'm ready it's everything's pretty your
body is ready
only i got the only thing i have to do
is cut the cheese
god everything sounds disgusting
no i got a slight saw i gotta slice off
yeah you cut your shirt
all right i'll put some chatter on that
[ __ ]
they're going nah what are you saying no
for tammy no
show or don't cover you or no don't
sketchy well it could be
could be why not both right yeah i mean
don't you know don't don't cut cheese on
the show
yeah no need from says have decided
maybe heavy metal again in the whole
tom tila i don't know exactly which what
he's talking about well i'm
my my uh my chat is way behind again so
i don't really i missed out on a bunch
of [ __ ]
yeah you know
what it what did i miss nothing i guess
are you sure oh yeah
they're they're it's it's sucking um
it's descending into chaos he's having
spell check
problems honor oh in the honor try to
decide maybe heavy metal again
in the name of uh honor in the name of
honor of tom
oh in honor of time okay
she goes okay gotcha have some good
sleep switch to the live chat
i don't know what they're saw heavy
metal upon tom and jenny's
recommendation
yeah oh that heavy metal movie is
[ __ ] good
even the extras on the blu-ray that i
have is really cool because they had
some deleted stuff
and they had an animated sequence on
there which showed where the loch gnar
came from and how it evolved up
through [ __ ] all of the through the
it invite it evolved up through the
biology of the earth
i liked that animation yeah it started
showing life
single-celled organisms [ __ ] eating
each other and then multicellular
organisms
fish eating each other and dinosaurs
eating each other and then it went to
[ __ ]
dinosaurs and [ __ ] man fighting and
man
fighting man and then them going up
through the damn roaming period and
they're all
killing each other and it just keeps
going up and then it shows [ __ ] jack
the ripper cutting up women and
everything the loch nars there [ __ ]
fueling it all and then it goes up to
the modern era
it was [ __ ] pretty cool it really
should have been in the movie but it was
like
it was hand sketched
yeah it was a cool style it looked
really [ __ ] cool
and i think that was supposed to be the
back story of the loch nar they were
supposed to show you that first
to get the movie rolling but they used a
different intro they used the
music and the guy coming down out of the
damn out of orbit in his [ __ ]
in his [ __ ] cattle in his it wasn't
it was a corvette
convertible corvette was it from the 50s
50 something corvette
astronaut [ __ ] drove it down that's
another way of doing it you know they
did it in more of a cool way instead of
a [ __ ] spooky way
but that old [ __ ] artwork spooky
other than
over cool every day that old 70s and
eras
era [ __ ] artwork all that hand
drawn [ __ ] that was [ __ ] fantastic
can i just say though
every time we talk about the loch ner
all i can think of is the coneheads
why is that i don't know we're not did
all their names end with
gnar i don't know it's been a long time
since
it's like the old snl sketches i don't
know just every time we watch heavy
metal and they talk about the lock gnar
i'm just like where the cone head
scott's asking what i thought of fire
and ice i need to see that again
that's on uh i'm pretty sure it's on
tubey if anybody wants to send us fire
and ice i'll review it
it's been a long time since i've seen it
all i remember is it was really good
animation
um it had it was a frazetta style
it may have been for zetta did the art
i'm not sure
but the men and the women had the had
like the physiques of something that
that uh rosetta would have done i
remember that it was the first time when
i was a kid
that i saw in actually animated
sequences
of of of women like walking around
and rolling around and that it was it
was actually
really attractive that i mean it looked
like an actual real woman
was it rotoscoping i don't know it may
have been
because i kind of feel like that might
have been rotoscope yeah it looked like
a real woman walking and
the the everything the way the body
moved it looked it looked exaggerated
but the exaggeration was a good effect i
mean i'm pretty sure that that was kind
of like the heyday of doing that type of
thing where you would like
you would basically draw over like a
real
and i'm pretty sure that's what they did
for heavy metal day you would draw over
a real like film of
like somebody there's a couple of
animated ones that i wanted to see
that i never did get to see i think
there was a british one called wizards
i saw posters for yeah i remember that
one i think i've seen bits of it i don't
know if i've ever sat through the whole
thing though
i saw i had post i had a poster for yeah
but i never saw the movie
it was we can do more animated movies we
should do we should do a double feature
of watership down and plague dogs
oh yeah man that would bum everybody out
i never saw plague dogs oh they're so
depressing
um i actually read the book watership
down too which is also depressing
but you know i'm kind of into that
honestly one of the
one animated film it's kind of more for
kids but i kind of dug it anyway was uh
the secret of them
you know what i mean i love it and i
just watched it again recently and i
liked it just as much
because i think that's on tubey or
amazon or something as well and i was
just kind of like
no it's on youtube for free or it was
i watched that because i was just like
excited that it was on there
i read that book as well which is
actually called mrs frisbie and the rats
of nim but it's the same story
i liked that um what was the the ralph
bakshi
hobbit the one with the ogres that sang
i liked that i didn't like the lord of
the rings that they did but the hobbit
was good
i liked that gollum you know scott
gattman mentioned something that was
very it does stand out as a truth he
said becky's are just
instruments of evolution yeah that's
true
well we all are i guess in a lot of
little ways
i don't i don't know what my what my
contribution is
but you know uh they said that fire and
ice was decent at plotting
that was uh no need it's not as good as
heavy metal no it's gonna save it man
i haven't seen it i mean i it's like i
said it's on to be
and i feel like i watched it not too
long ago because i was thinking about
doing it for the show like we were going
to do a heavy metal fire and ice double
feature
which we still could do at some point
but we'll see how it goes
because somebody sent a sentence heavy
metal a while back yeah that's a great
movie
i think that might have been hernandez
it might be it might have been louis
well honestly for a matinee maybe we
should do heavy metal and fire and ice
like in one show
because they're kind of similar we did
heavy metal already
i don't think we ever did though we
never did heavy battle no i'm pretty
sure we never didn't have
well because like i said you know i
think louie sent it to us
i'm pretty sure louis center or maybe
michael did but i'm pretty sure it was
louie
and um and i kept putting in the poll
and it never won
like it always got votes but it never
won so i don't think we ever did
it so we should do that i've we probably
have like talked about it at various
times but we should do that and fire and
ice like on one show
that would be good like a double feature
no need for me says it's natural becky
selection
natural becky's yeah you have to
understand something okay
in the evolutionary process of the south
the becky was selected for survival
okay that's what was selected that's
what
made it through the maze of of
tests that happens in the south when
you're dealing with things like grits
and cornbread
and limited employment and [ __ ] lack
little debbie's
little daddy cakes lack of internet
connection
like back in the 1800s you know not
getting eaten by alligators
yeah yeah there's a lot of factors
exactly
[ __ ] dealing with males that didn't
have any kind of [ __ ] high quality
entertainment this goes back to the
[ __ ] 18
1700s a becky will emerge from the fro
from from and becky's emerge
from the swamp of [ __ ] the genetic
swamp
yeah i just had a really funny mental
image of like a becky coming out like a
tar pit
yeah yeah yeah oh my god
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's how it is
the loch nar was watching sure the loch
nara was [ __ ] watching dear and all
that was observing
and he saw that it was good yeah he saw
it
get worried about cup size and not a
supply
supply of support yeah is it possible to
support
yeah that's worrying about [ __ ] like
that
yeah holy [ __ ] crap yeah i can't
believe where this is the taxonomy of
becky's
yeah i never thought that we would like
get into that [ __ ] area yeah but okay
taxonomy of becky becky's taxonomy of
karen's
becky's uh becky's were ingenious and
very creative
for their kind they invented the cutoffs
yeah they [ __ ] just cut them [ __ ]
shorts
becky's the first one to think of that
truth
it was all all because of lack of
central air conditioning
[Laughter]
you know did becky's invent the tube top
yeah
[ __ ] right
yeah that is definitely a becky [ __ ]
thing that's the bet you adventure hell
yeah
i started from the 70s it required
minimal sewing skills
you just make a tube and you put that
[ __ ] on you there you go
you know what i mean yeah i just made
that out of my hand my pantyhose
yeah it is like them and they shake them
like that and then you like them
yeah yeah yeah and then she's pregnant
it's part of the
it's part of the it's part of the
reproductive cycle
the reproductive cycle of the becky yeah
we need to make like a chart for this
yeah we can teach this in classes it's
very important hard to know who the
father is though
what's the problem oh my god yeah you're
trying to make a [ __ ] family tree and
there's like a lot of available mails
you're not sure which one it was
yeah it's just all question marks yeah
the question marks
is there okay now here's a here's a good
question is there a mail equivalent of a
becky yeah
and what is it oh you don't know
i'm not a student i'm not a student of
that i don't know i thought you might be
um
i mean i know that there's kind of
change throughout the throughout there's
kind of a male equivalent of a karen
yeah would it would a chad be a male
equivalent of a karen
well it's not quite the same a chad is a
different
that's a different species altogether no
i'm trying to remember
i i'll come up with it
it's like a tammy says is it the wrong
time to mention my real name is becky
sent us a photo probably
[Laughter]
tammy's doing this she's pregnant yeah
that's right yeah you're dealing with
that's how that happens
sure yeah oh my god
oh [ __ ] they're still talking i'm i'm
behind because they're still talking
about like
which is what i was talking about like a
few minutes ago before we get started
said tom might be the might be a the
male version of a becky
is it although to be honest with you
you're the only tom that i know
well you're not the only time that i
know because i know another but you're
the only tom
there's not enough toms yeah i didn't
know any tom's growing up that's what i
meant because we i know
a couple of times nowadays other than
you but trying to remember
growing up i didn't know anybody named
mostly named like rick
i didn't know any ricks either um no i
didn't know one richard
but that was in elementary school i knew
a lot of michael's
yeah mike i knew or michael's or mike's
i knew a lot of that i knew a lot of
gems a lot of gyms i didn't really know
any gyms
um but and i'm talking about like when i
was growing up like i'm trying to think
of the most common names like from high
school
i knew some david's i knew i knew a lot
of david i knew a [ __ ] ton of brian's
and actually my one of my brother's
names is uh brian my youngest brother's
name brian
i knew a lot of brian a lot of brian's
brian was like the
the heather of boys in my schools yeah
at least
there was a lot of bryant yeah yeah
other than that [ __ ] man i can't really
think of yeah i knew some richards
not they weren't rick or dick though
they were richard
yeah you know which i like better
because i don't like rick or dick it's
either one of those are good she don't
like dick
well as a name no okay and rick
rick sounds like a dj's name yeah like a
like a shitty wedding dj's name
you know what i mean i don't know why to
me
jesus says wasn't there a becky
character in tom swore i think there was
there was yeah
yeah yeah yeah
was she one of their aunts or sisters or
[ __ ] i can't
i haven't read that a long time i think
becky was
was huck's [ __ ] love interest wasn't
it wouldn't she
wasn't she the girl that hung out with
him maybe but like i said it's been a
long time since i read that
been a long time since i read it look my
[ __ ] crashed again yeah are we still
going though yeah we're still going we
got to shut it down though it's getting
[ __ ] hokey
it's getting hokey yeah it's gonna
you're gonna live you're gonna lose that
connection and it's time for me to cook
something
getting late i'm hungry yeah and we've
been going like for more than
yeah we going along more than yeah we
want to thank you guys
we want to thank you guys for all the
super chats it was a good time you guys
are awesome we love hanging out with you
guys
i wanted to give a shout out to um i
forgot to mention earlier but i want to
give a shout to ryan i don't think he's
here
but he sent me a really nice uh a long
uh patreon message which i'm going to
actually answer tomorrow i didn't have
time to do it today
but um you know and he he was saying how
cool it was
just to get like shattered out on the
show because a lot of people are kind of
like
you know lonely hanging out with us
and we like hanging out with you guys
too yeah so it's cool that
you guys come and tease that spawn show
listen to us babbling
yeah tea i'm gonna hold you to it you're
gonna host you're gonna co-host the show
one of these days
i'm gonna have a little picture of you
right there we can see you
we could talk yeah cuz i bet you she'd
be funny as hell
he's doing something like building yes
he should yeah
maybe when i'm on vacation you can come
in here and live stream and like [ __ ]
if you know how to do it yeah do you
know how to do it well now why are you
we're on
we're both going to show you we're going
to both going to be on vacation
you're not going to okay i'm not going
to do that because i was going to say i
did i couldn't i was trying to decide
well i got to take one of my laptops
with me i don't know if i want to take
this one because there's so much [ __ ]
attached to it i might just take my mac
even though it's kind of like because at
least i can check my email on that
and i'm going to send everybody an email
and be like [ __ ] off on vacation cause i
don't want to be bothering me
they got a lot of people that are
[ __ ] funny we have [ __ ] hernandez
on there [ __ ] garcia
i know you guys are here yeah yeah
[ __ ]
yeah one of these days we'll have a
we'll have a group chat that'd be cool
to have a group show
that would actually yeah a lot of other
channels do it if my laptop can handle
it
we have to [ __ ] figure out that we
might have another laptop by then or
yeah
if we can upgrade another one at one
point because like i said it's kind of a
cheap jackman
yeah we need to get like a 400 one
or maybe even more than yeah we'll see
well we'll see
we'll see but yeah i can't see the chat
but he can see it i can see it though
they're all saying goodbye
so you guys have a good rest of your
evening we will be back on friday night
we're going to be talking about
the uncaught serial killer the west mesa
bone collector
that's like scary [ __ ] happened in the
early 2000s
and uh so we'll be talking about that on
friday night and tomorrow
i'm gonna put up a movie review so we'll
have other [ __ ] going on that you come
on fun seeing you guys we'll see you
around we'll see you around later
we'll see you guys later on